النت واوكرانيا لن يدعى روسيا تنتصر في
الحرب هكذا اسمع الجميع خلال جلسه الجمعيه
العامه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في مدريد اجمع
الحضور على المفهوم الاستراتيجي للحلفي
وعلى زياده المساعده
لقواتكرانيون الثمن بدمائهم اذا سمحنا
التكلفه ستكون باهضه علينا جميعا لن نسمح
للرئيس بوتن بالانتصار في اوكرانيا
كلمه الرئيس الاوكراني عن بعض تضمنت
مطالبه قديمه وجديده
على انها دوله ارهابيه كما اود ان توصل
بلدانكم الحفاظ على العقوبه المفروضه على
روسيا اعتقد ان العقوبه مهمه جدا من اجل
منع استمرار هذه الحرب وان تمتد تلك
العقوبات وقتا طويلا نحتاج الى حزم جديده
من العقوبات ضد روسيا بسبب هذه الحرب
الارهابيه داخل هذه القاعه رددت جمله
الحرب ستكون مكلفه وطويله هل يعني ذلك
اغلاق الطريق امام المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه
لانهاء الصراع طبابيا ومتناقضا احيانا
يبدو النقاشه بشان الرغبه او المساعد
الامريكيه من اجل جلوس طرفي الحرب
الى طاوله التفاوض وقد تعكس الرسائل
المباشره والمبطنه بهذا الخصوص وجوده
خلافات داخل نفسها ولكن لا يراد لها ان
تظهر للعلم واشنطن حريصه دائما على الحفاظ
على صوره الحلف المتماسك منذ نشوب الحرب
تكرر ان الامر متروك للرئيس زيلانكي ليقول
ما اذا كان مستعدا للمفاوضات ومتى وما
الشكل الذي ستتخذه تلك المفاوضات
والمفارقه ان البيت الابيض لم يعارض
تصريحات الجنرال مارك ميلي التي تحدث فيها
عن ضروره اغتنام فرص التفاوض لتحقيق
السلام
التفاوض واشبه بطلب استسلام اوكرانيا علق
في وقت سابق مستشار الرئيس
ما تسميه انتصاراتها الاخيره
البدايه لاستعاده كل اراضيها من القوات
الروسيه بنظر بعض حلفائها تقدمها العسكري
فرصه قد لا تتكرر للدخول في حوار مع موسكو
من منطلق قوه
ضعف حتى وان جهر الغرب ان القرار بيدك يف
الكل يعلم ان اليد التي تقدم المال
والسلاح في الحرب هي اليد العليا في مسائل
كثيره ومنها الحوار الدبلوماسي لانهاء
الحربي المكلفه جدا